allez on en vient notre séquence
recherche innovation comme chaque
vendredi dans le 12/13 ce midi on vous
présente
j'ai au motif une implication pour
découvrir ou redécouvrir le patrimoine
local et gersois le fondateur sylvain
lambert bonjour merci d'être avec nous
sylvain expliquez nous comment
fonctionne cette application une
application assez simple qui a pour but
de vous faire découvrir votre patrimoine
ou découvrir par l'angle par le biais de
l'ornementation c'est à dire des détails
qui vous entourent au quotidien
alors concrètement on attrape des
détails des édifices un peu comme on
attrapait ou comme on attrape encore les
fameux pokémon go exactement plutôt que
d'attraper des airs à tata et des
pikachu vous je vais vous emmener
découvrir début crâne déambulant
d'hérens eau et des gargouilles
autant d'objets qui vous entourent au
quotidien alors on le voit par exemple a
tout de suite au château de chamerolles
là dans le loiret
que peut-on attrapé précisément vous
venez de l'évoquer mais que peut-on par
exemple et des dauphins
alors grâce âgée au motif d'abord vous
pouvez trouver par exemple l'amour au
château de sully sur loire donc un amour
attrapé vous pouvez trouver une licorne
au château de chamerolles ou encore des
femmes sauvages et des hommes sauvages
dans les rues d'orléans par exemple et
du coup il ya toutes les explications
liées à leur notation
alors vous avez une partie très ludique
qui consiste à superposer des calques
d'architecturé à la réalité pour pouvoir
progresser dans le jeu vous obtenez un
peu d'informations sur le lieu mais ce
n'est pas un guide de visite et vous en
savez plus sur la définition du motif
grâce à la base de connaissances
embarqué qui est le vocabulaire illustré
l'ornement et c'est finalement l'un des
jeux pour toute la famille comment vous
avez eu l'idée de cette application
c'est la découverte de ce livre
justement qui m'a permis d'automatiser
ville thomas voilà aux éditions eyrolles
qui m'a permis de tomber amoureux de ce
patrimoine
et comme j'étais pas du tout passionné
ni l'histoire ni l' architecture
ben voila j'ai voulu faire partager
cette expérience qui m'a permis de
redécouvrir et de donner envie d'en
savoir plus et justement vous êtes un
ancien de l'aéronautique
un ancien des assurances oui et vous
avez décidé de tout plaquer pour lancer
cette application
alors j'ai tout plaqué oui mais pas pour
lancer cette application c'est venu dans
un deuxième temps je cherchais un projet
et
en fait a lancé à créer pour et la
découverte voilà de ce livre ne
travailler que j'ai pu faire avec
evelyne thomas qui m'a donné l'idée
voilà de développer cette application
pour partager cette expérience dans
quels sites de la région peut-on
découvrir les détails d'édifices ya
plusieurs sites alors je crois oui alors
les partenaires aujourd'hui ça va tout a
commencé à orléans
voilà dans la ville d'orléans donc il ya
quatre parcours à orléans mais on peut
il jouer à tour on peut y jouer à
bourges
on peut y jouer à nevers aussi et dans
lé château de sully sur loire et de
chamerolles depuis le mois de septembre
est normalement le château devient aussi
dès l'année prochaine et dans d'autres
villes à venir et notamment grâce à des
parcours renaissance
alors il faut le dire l'application est
totalement gratuite et vous êtes
installé au labo d'orléans lave le
fameux incubateur de start le mans vous
êtes soutenus à je suis soutenue de a à
z et là le fait de faire partie du
labeaume a donné évidemment une
visibilité et des outils pour développer
mon offre et m'accompagner dans le
développement d'une activité et le champ
des possibles est assez un peu
importants alors aujourd'hui évidemment
pour des raisons pour faire la
démonstration de la preuve de mon
concept j'ai travaillé en région centre
maintenant le but du jeu est de
m'étendre à l'ensemble du territoire et
au-delà
et voilà et en ce sens le labo
m'accompagne pour pouvoir atteindre ses
objectifs et bien france 3 sans que vous
accompagne également merci beaucoup
sylvain lambert d'avoir été en direct et
rythme sur le merci à vous j'ai au motif
est disponible sur android et bien sûr
apple store